now I know you don't really like York
watch much TV yes
has he been introduced to the original
life-size yet
you
he has not been introduced to the
original life-size but based on me doing
some like I go into the editing Bay for
like all day at a time many days at a
time to edit the movie but then those to
me like scenes on my phone and I have to
kind of like look at stuff and make
notes and he is transfixed by that when
he sees me doing that there's something
about this movie I was just telling
Francia this there's something about the
movie where he just like gets lost and
he's seen me in TV and stuff before and
is not that impressed with this and he's
just like mommy he likes it now do you
remember when little KC lost her mama
did I throw on the towel
no I didn't I shined bright I shined far
I was a stock maybe because it's so
bright and colorful and he's all glammed
up that's what I think yeah it's
exaggeration he's getting to the age
where holidays he's gonna have membranes
Oh No are you doing anything extra
special this year um not yet I'm just I
don't know this is my first child so
right now it's just gonna be pretty
traditional we're gonna have our tree
we're gonna sing Santa's gonna come down
the chimney
Santa's we're gonna put the cookies out
with the milk and I'm gonna have to wake
up at 3 o'clock in the morning and bite
them cookies and drink some of that warm
milk sitting on the counter so those are
the traditions that I had as a little
noodle one and I'm gonna bring those to
him have you thought about when you'll
show him the original life-size I have
not but I think we need to do that
before the image and the new one
bearable a double feature yes heirs
before the second one on the summer
she's still a fan to this day Emma this
is grace and this is Eve that's why
doesn't he I know I know this one is the
success that we all know it's gonna be
stable again I've been waiting nearly 20
years for it do you think a third life
size could happen I think there
definitely will probably be a future of
life sighs um brother I made it work
whether I'm in it or not I don't know
but I do feel that the franchise is is
definitely massive and we shall see if
I'll be okay would you continue on with
life sighs yeah I would work with Tyra
again in any
this one is fantastic
[Music]